you are literally always working and i  asked you like when do you have fun how  do you balance that work and play life i  don't think anybody can work hard hard  unless they like it i was the least  hard-working student in the history of  this country i got ds and f's for real i  love everyone's like gary's the hustle  guy  first 18 years of my life all i was told  was i was lazy i just didn't like it now  everyone's like oh too much i'm like you  can never do too much of what you love  the only thing i strive for is enjoyment  of my process that's all i've ever known  it's why i was so bad at school i  understood its importance on paper i  just hated the process i'm out incapable  lazy lazy